Thoughts that should not be controversial. I don't like Marvel movies oh
It is controversial
Oh, No how do I preface this video without getting any hate if you like Marvel movies don't worry
That's your opinion, and I just have mine. I made a video a few days ago
Saying why I don't like Marvel movies, and I sort of memed it pretty hard and people got really angry, and I didn't realize
People were so passionately defensive about Marvel movies for some reason. And since so many people had so many different thoughts around it
I thought why don't I just go a little deeper with my point on why I don't like them or at least why I don't
Like them anymore. My first argument was : over saturation
I don't know how anyone can really defend this point, but I'll go through it anyway. We have Iron Man.
You had the Hulk, Iron Man again, Thor, Captain America
Avengers, Iron Man again, Thor again, Captain America again, Guardians of the Galaxy
Avengers again
Aaaant-Maaaaan
Civil War, Doctor Strange, Guardians of the Galaxy again, thank God. Spooderman
Thor again
And Black Panther.  Oh you thought that was it. No no no no no let's not forget about X-Men, Logan, Wolverine, X-Men, X-Men, X-Men
Spider-man, Spider-man, Spider-man, Spider-man
Deadpool
Daredevil
Fantastic Four and Fantastic Four. I'm definitely wrong for being tired of Marvel movies. I just don't understand how
How I can.. I know it's completely unrea.. sonable
To think that way there's just no way at all to come up with this conclusion
I must just be crazy or something. Now don't get me wrong. I really liked superhero movies growing up. Spider-man for example
I thought was so cool to see a
superhero movie that I
recognized on the big screen for the very first time. It wasn't something I was familiar with before and I just thought that
concept was really really cool
But then once you watch one two three four five six you sort of get that...
they're all the same movie packaged differently.
They all follow the same story and concept at the end of the day sure Deadpool is a very different superhero than spider-man
But at the end of the day all these films can be summarized as : superhero has superpowers.
Super villain has superpowers. Super hero wants peace. Super villain wants destruction. They fight and super hero wins.
Hooray
Please direct me to any one of these thirty movies that doesn't follow this format.
You know at the end of the movie where the villain is fighting the superhero, and there's this...
This moment of suspense where you feel like  "Oh shit
I really want the superhero to win"
But then you know "Oh the movies about to wrap up any minute now" because he's about to fight back aaaand
the superhero will win aaand
There will be a happy shot where everyone is just happy in the end and : "The End". It just removes any form of joy of
Suspense because you... they are so painfully predictable. If at least one of these movies
Went on a different path at least I would think okay, maybe this one will be different
But it's all the same. Every. Single. Time. And digging deeper into the meat and the bone of the films
I won't get too much into every single aspect, but one thing that I personally don't enjoy about these Marvel
movies specifically is that they rely so heavily on special effects
It just feels too unreal, it just feels too unrealistic.
It's like I'm watching an animated film with nothing really artistically interesting or impressive about it as opposed to Dark Knight for example where
Where you watch this scene and you're like "Whoa they actually did flip a giant truck in the middle of New York City
That's really cool. There's something interesting and admirable about that"
You have the John Wick films, which I'm not gonna show 'cause it'll get demonetized
but you see the talent of Keanu Reeves the actor, you see his movement and you see what he does. He doesn't need a
thousand animators working on every single detail of the shot trying to make the person look cool.
It's the... it's the actor himself
being cool. "Shits on Marvel, watches anime", "Felix bashes Marvel and superhero movies and praises anime. Shut up Felix".
"Movies based on comic books are better than your stupid anime shows", "d
Don't watch superhero films because they're not real...
says the anime fan.",  "They're for kids, says the guy who decorates his room with anime garbage."
There's just so much wrong with this, I don't even know where to begin. First of all
I don't like anime, I know, I know, I know, calm down. I love anime.
I don't like Shonen anime. Shonen anime is what's targeted for teens between 12 and 18.
And that's the same thing really with Marvel movies,
they're... they're for teenagers.
But for some reason it's still allowed for grown men to enjoy and cry about these films being interesting.
It's like watching adults cry about Naruto. Sure, I loved Naruto and I loved One Piece, and I loved
Bleach when I was a teenager. But then after going through all of them you sort of realize, same thing with Marvel films,
They're all the same thing...
packaged differently. You know what you're going to get, you know what you can expect out of these forms of media
so after a while it just doesn't become appealing anymore because you've already
experienced it, you already know what you're gonna get out of it.
But even then...
Okay
If you're gonna bring up the whole concept of anime atleast you have atleast
hundreds of thousands of people coming up with hundreds of ideas and
literally only the best ones will truly stick and you have some really interesting and unique
concepts of characters and all these things, instead of just one guy coming up with different (whut) of basically the same concept.
People worship Stan Lee like he's some sort of godlike creature a... and... which gives me to my... eh
...my next point which is the cult surrounding the Marvel movies.
It's freaky. It's weird.
It's a guy dressed in a suit.You're screaming at a guy dressed in a suit.
But Felix it's my childhood.
I grew up watching... I grew up reading comic books
A lot of people said this argument to me as well that
They just grew up with comic books and that's why they gets so excited about it.
But I don't really get that either to be honest. I practically grew up playing World of Warcraft
I couldn't care less about the Warcraft movie.
I... I loved watching Star Wars movies as a kid, but now I'm just not interested in them anymore.
I just don't understand this point. Moving on to my next point which I brought up in my original video
which is : we need to stop fetishizing
the idea of idolizing superheroes.
I genuinely think it's damaging, and I say this because they're not real and everyone just completely jumped on me saying
"Well Felix anime isn't real, so what's your..."
My point wasn't that it wasn't real. My point is that it's super...
They have superpowers right ? It's not achievable to have superpowers
You're idolizing something that's impossible
You're idolizing a personal trait that just has been giving to them most of the times for free. If you want to bring up anime again
Then at least Naruto worked hard to get his powers
To become who he is. He didn't just get superpowers by biting of a goddamn spider
Okay, ju... let's drop the whole anime point, my point is that what's what's so admirable about
idolizing a superhero ? What is the positive message? The fact that they want to do something good? Is that what's so...
So great about them? That they're striving to make the world a better place?
Oh whooping 'i do who does it? What about a superhero movie that tackles the idea of
what really is good and what really is evil? Oh wait!
They already did that and he sure as hell wasn't Marvel! "You either die a hero
Or you live long enough to see yourself become a villain"
There are a good superhero movies still, I'm not... I'm not denying that but Marvel
just are so shallow.
They all just rely on looking cool, and having quirky and dumb jokes everywhere. And never giving you something actually of substance
That's why I get so bored watching them, and... and... and don't get me wrong
I'm not even a DC fanboy, like I've given up on that as well. "Congrats to the entire black panther team!
Because of you, young people will finally see superheroes that look like them on the big screen."
Way to put more emphasis on race than what is necessary at all. That's right
I can't idolize anime figures because I'm not Japanese that's just impossible
Oh, that's right. I can't idolize Lightning McQueen from Cars 1 and 2 because he's a vehicle of transportation
And I'm just a mere mortal human being. Why not teach kids that their own morals and values
Comes from themselves, and not from their skin. Instead of: "Oh you look like this person so... you can be like this!
Because you have the same complexion of skin!" And even if this idea was so great
Why did it take
18 films for Black Panther to come out? Is it because social politics is more popular than ever and it's actually very
monetizable? Or it's because they actually want to do something good and positive
Hmm, I wonder which one. And if it's so admirable
Why hasn't there been a female superhero movie yet?
Why... I know that's coming out, but it's like after what, 20 of them?
Why hasn't there been as Mexican superhero yet hmm? Why not an Eskimo? Hello?
I am an Eskimo, who am I supposed to idolize here? I am so lost!
Last but not least, in Infinity War apparently a big deal of the movie is that a lot of superheroes... Die.
But I'm not gonna spoil which ones or anything like that, but let's just entertain the idea that
let's say Iron Man dies in... in Infinity War. Do you actually... And people are treating this like
this is a really big deal, but do you actually think they're gonna just then stop making Iron Man movies?
Do you think that franchise is just somehow completely gone? There are gonna be prequels, there are gonna be different (whut again), different actors
They're still making Spider-man movies. That's sort of the point: as long as they keep making money
it's not gonna stop. And to me personally there's something very unappealing about that.
It... It sort of lacks any form of artistic integrity. Sure a lot of anime suffer from this as well
They just don't know when to stop as long as they keep making money then they're gonna keep going.
But there's so many other great movies that are completely overshadowed by all these comic book movies that are all to me
the same thing. If you're a teenager I couldn't care less if you like these movies like knock yourself out
I enjoyed them as a teenager as well.
But seeing the cult of frantic screaming adults crying about these movies still, it's insane to me.
I think there's something wrong about our culture, and this is not stopping anytime soon.
There's so many movies still coming out as you can see here
They already announced half of them. Who actually cares about the next Ant-Man? Like it blows my mind,
I don't get it. You... You literally have a new superhero movie out before the next one even comes out on the DVD
How many superhero movies do you need? At the end of the day
I don't care. You... You're free to like whatever you want.
I... Like it doesn't bother me if I meet someone that say they like it
I just personally don't agree with it, and here's the reason why I don't like Marvel movies.
Thank you for watching this video. Leave a like if you agree with me. Leave two likes if you
disagree with me. Check out represent.com/pewdiepie. It's a great way to support the channel, and we sold over 10.000 of
the merch so far, I am extremely grateful. Thank you to everyone who supported it, it really
It's incredible. I'm very very proud and very very thankful, so thank you.
Be free and be happy, do whatever you want. I... At the end of the day, I don't care This is just a rant video